if there really was a limitless style
smart pill that could transform your
brain to reach its full potential what
would you hope it would be like for me
it would be something that could trigger
amazing ideas and insight because more
than being able to do fast mental
arithmetic or being able to reel off
huge lists of facts having great ideas
is what can really change your life and
if you have a truly amazing idea it
could help you to become extraordinarily
rich or to change the course of human
understanding true genius is not mastery
of a subject but the ability to totally
shift the paradigm in this post I'll be
breaking down moments of ideation the
stories of great thinkers who had
game-changing ideas and from this will
gone on what was going on inside their
brains what perhaps stimulated those
ideas and what we can all do to nurture
this skill so why not start with
Einstein's theories of special and
general relativity as these are two of
the most influential ideas that we've
seen in recent times special relativity
was Einstein's first stab at this theory
and he reportedly came up with the idea
while working in a patent office between
1905 and 1907 it's often been suggested
that it was the repetitive busy work of
ticking off patents and perhaps exposure
to all those unique ideas that allowed
his creative juices to flow as the brain
relaxes so the pattern of brain activity
becomes more dispersed as neurons fire
at different parts of the brain the
novel connections can be formed which in
turn can provide new insights they say
that new ideas are simply combinations
of older existing ideas this is why you
cannot force an idea and it's why you'll
often find the solutions to problems
precisely when you take a break from
that work as a programmer
I'll regularly fix the issues I've been
struggling over right when I take a
toilet break Alexander Fleming
discovered penicillin not by scrolling
biochemical equations on a chalkboard
fueled by caffeine but by playing around
and painting ballerinas with that
bacteria many of us find our most
creative ideas happen when we're in the
shower or walking and this is a state
where we're just busy enough just like
that Patent Office to keep our bodies
busy while our minds can wander freely
and activate the default mode net
so the default mode network is the areas
of the brain associated with imagination
and planning which kick into gear when
we have no other pressing tasks this
network is also sometimes referred to as
the imagination network so many people
preach the importance of being in the
now and living in the moment in fact
though healthy daydreaming can be
extremely useful and it's one of the
things that makes us uniquely human this
is why I always say there's no such
thing as n unuseful brain state it
doesn't come up in conversation that
often so I don't always say it but you
know what I mean one of the best ways to
activate your default mode network is
walking and ideally walking in nature
which has the added benefit of providing
relaxing and calming stimuli in the form
of fauna etc walking is actually
responsible for many great ideas
throughout history
Nikola Tesla for instance count the idea
of alternating current while taking a
stroll with friends he reportedly used
his walking stick to illustrate the idea
to them as they walked Nietzsche once
said that all truly great thoughts are
conceived by walking Steve Jobs was
known for taking long walks in countless
writers from jean-jacques rousseau to
William Blake to Wordsworth all used
walking to tap into the creativity and
it was similarly while letting his mind
wander that Einstein had the happiest
thought of his life as he called it when
he imagined what song would see when
falling from a roof whilst holding an
object he realized that from the
perspective of the individual falling
there would be no gravity because the
object would fall at the same speed but
the other unique aspect of einstein's
eureka moment and of the default mode
network in general is visualization
einstein visually understood relativity
by imagining that image before he put it
into words now we have the luxury of
being able to examine einstein's brain
we know that it had some unique
anomalies a thicker bundle of neurons
connecting the two hemispheres called
the corpus callosum and larger inferior
parietal lobes which were involved in
visualization and spatial and
mathematical reasoning in short
visualization is an extremely useful
tool when it comes to ideation and in
many cases Einstein might have had an
advantage in this area
thanks to neuroplasticity you can
actually train your visualization skills
and potentially grow your own inferior
parietal lobes playing 3d computer games
can do this as can practicing
visualization with methods like
image streaming created by win winger
which I made a video about and a post in
the past you'll find a link in the
description below real world visual cues
are also often involved in the Eureka
moments acting as kind of a catalyst
whereas Einstein used visualization we
all know the stories of Archimedes who
discovered displacement when getting
into a bathtub and of Isaac Newton who
understood gravity after seeing an Apple
fall to the ground though these stories
may have been embellished over time
DaVinci observed how water would push a
stick in a stream and used this to
understand the concept of lift for his
flying machines these cues help to
provide a starting point but by being
able to visualize we can manipulate
objects and ideas in our minds and find
new applications for them or gain new
insight this is further facilitated by
entering that relaxed imagination rich
state that allows freeform thinking
going even further many great ideas come
from dreams this is when our minds are
allowed to explore completely bizarre
and novel connections in an entirely
unfettered manner while exercising all
of the senses and modalities together
niels bohr created his model of the atom
based on a dream that showed him a
positively charged nucleus with
electrons orbiting like planets and
dmitri mendeleev created the periodic
table after falling into a dream
listening to a musical symphony and
seeing the elements flow together like
the progressions of a musical sequence
isn't just more extreme examples of
people have forgotten about a problem or
a creative task only to have their break
continue to work on it during a kind of
incubation period Steven Johnson calls
this the slow hunch and uses Darwin as
an example dones notes show that he had
the germination of his big idea
long before the final Epiphany the
Eureka moment is simply when it all
clicked into place indeed this kind of
unexpected insight is what led many
throughout history to believe that truly
great work was due to divine inspiration
the work of God or spirits known as
demons for demons we can teach ourselves
to remember more of our dreams by
keeping a dream diary but is coming up
with genius really just a matter of
relaxing and doing a name work and going
to sleep notice that in many example
scenarios the seed of the idea were
planted prior to the dream or the
incubation period that is to say that
the individual was working on the
problem before going to sleep the idea
may happen whilst they take the break
but they first need to prime their minds
for the creative insight in other words
ethically loading the brain with
relevant topics and then taking a break
could help your mind to work on that
problem rather than thinking about your
favorite TV show equally important is
spending a significant amount of time
researching and absorbing the topic take
the story of Archimedes while the Eureka
moment may have happened in the bathtub
or not he had actually been working for
Hiram king of the Sicilian city Syracuse
to create the largest ship ever
Archimedes challenge was understanding
how such a large object could float in
other words his discovery of the law of
buoyancy was likely simply the happy end
product of countless hours of relevant
research thought and study
likewise Einstein would not discovered
relativity had he never had exposure to
mathematics or physics
Jules Henri Poincare discovered a unique
property of fusion functions when
randomly stepping into a bus during a
geological expedition but only after
spending weeks attempting to better
understand to no avail he said at the
moment when I put my foot on the step
the idea came to me without anything in
my former thoughts seeming to have paved
way for it you can consider our brains
creative processes then as an input and
output situation the input is relevant
information and inspiration the output
is a new idea the more input you provide
the more unique combinations your brain
will be able to give you back seeking
inspiration and analogous ideas then can
also help
for example da Vinci would spend huge
amounts of time studying the flights of
birds in order to better inform his own
flying contraptions another angle on
this is that the best ideas happen in
conversation I've certainly elaborated
on some of my best ideas whilst
discussing them with friends or even
just telling them about them likewise we
could make the Tesla was with friends
when discussing alternating current in
his TED talk Stephen Johnston describes
the role of conversation in cultivating
good ideas conversation in many ways
acts like a wandering thought naturally
traveling from association to
Association while allowing input though
from multiple individuals this allows
more completely novel combinations of
concepts here a group of people become a
kind of liquid network to use his
lexicon or an EXO cortex this is why the
introduction of the coffeehouse is
likely at least one catalyst for the
introduction of many great ideas and
possibly even the Enlightenment as a
whole and finally to kill the idea that
creativity is simply a matter of
switching off we have the concept of
active imagination described initially
by psychologist Carl Jung this is
imagination with a purpose where you
actively use the same lateral thinking
and free-flowing visualization to
intentionally tackle a problem this is
something that can be achieved with time
and practice Cal Newport author of deep
work recommends a similar strategy
referred to as productive meditation
this is meditation where you simply
think deeply on a given problem for a
set amount of time completely
unrestrained and undirected thinking
will often result in pure nonsense the
random combinations of ideas need to be
useful in one study it was found that
the most successful creative thinking
actually occurs when both the default
mode Network and the executive control
Network are in use simultaneously the
executive control network is the brain
network responsible for controlling our
attention usually towards external
stimuli when you turn that attention
inwards though the result can be
magnificent the rub though is that
normally activating the executive
control network will automatically
switch off the default mode network so
if there's a problem you're trying to
solve what can you do
spend some time researching and learning
about it speak with friends about it
freely and openly don't dismiss any
ideas are stupid research as much of it
as you can then go for a long walk when
you get home why not try some productive
meditation and finally failing all else
let yourself fall into a deep sleep take
the fan this video useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
please comment down below and share it
around I've got lots more cool stuff on
the way as always on the brain on the
body on working out on self-improvement
online business we're well on the way
now to 100,000 subscribers thank you so
much for that and once we reach that
milestone
that's when hopefully things will get
really interesting so yeah thanks a ton
for sticking with me and I'll see you
next time bye for now